[Musique]
mais
non
[Musique]
moi je suis luc joly de lo griyo et je
suis brice du groupe lo griyo également
c'est quoi le griot c'est une machine de
guerre voilà alors le vo c'est un
quartet de musique instrumentale
réunionnaise avec une batterie une basse
saxophone et une cour à c'est peut-être
l'instrument le plus particulier est un
instrument d'origine africaine
comme beaucoup de groupes aujourd'hui on
mélange plein d' influence donc il ya du
jazz il ya des musiques du smatah les
musiques du monde
sauf que je connais pas de musique qui
viennent pas du monde mais bref cette
parenthèse il y à du rock il ya de
l'électronique et et on essaie de faire
un truc cohérent on essaye j'ai bien
essayé de faire un truc cohérent avec
toutes ces infos
c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
faut venir nous voir peut-être parce
qu'on essaie des choses mais c'est en
toute humilité on essaie de trouver un
son un peu particulier là on n'est
certes pas être prétentieux pour autant
mais on a un groupe qui cherche et on
est fiers et contents de chercher on n'a
pas envie de trouver un envie de
chercher et si on retrouve au passage
c'est bien mais on a envie surtout envie
de chercher et on essaie de cultiver une
relative
originalité et pour le public c'est bien
de je trouve de voir des gens extérieurs
avec des gens d'ici et voir comment ça
se passe quoi le mot de la fin il faut
venir vendredi nous voir jouer
surtout que je crois que ça me à une
nouvelle chemise en jean chemise pour le
pantalon non mais
[Rires]
[Musique]